-As always, you look great.
You're a stud.
They love you. We love you.
Welcome back. Come on.
-Thank you for having me.
-We have a thousand things
to talk about.
-Do we?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Last time you were here,
you were engaged.
Now officially,
you are married.
Congratulations.
That's the great thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How was the wedding?
How was everybody?
-Honestly?
-Yeah.
-It was pretty seamless.
Like everybody,
friends and family warned us.
They were like,
"Just be prepared.
Something's going to go wrong.
That's fine.
You know, just let it
roll off your shoulder."
-Yes.
-But honestly,
nothing went wrong.
It was perfect.
-Really?
-It was -- You know, we did it
at a place we loved.
Little wine country,
pretty close to where we live.
-Big wedding?
-I would say
on the smaller side.
It was like just under 100.
-That's perfect.
-It was. It was perfect.
-And how long now
have you been married?
-Well, in...
-Uh-oh.
-Right? Oh, dang!
-Here's where it all went wrong.
I'm so sorry.
-No, I'm just trying to do math.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay. Wedding was 11/11, so...
-Almost a year.
-Yeah. Less than -- Yeah.
In less than two weeks,
we'll have our one-year
anniversary.
-Wow. Hey!
I'm so happy for you, buddy.
-Thank you.
-You're co-hosting
with your wife
this podcast
called "The Squeeze,"
and it is streaming now.
I love that her name
is Taylor as well.
-Yeah.
-And so she became
Taylor Lautner when she got
married to you.
-Yes, I know.
-I think it's great.
-Do you?
-Yes.
-It's quite narcissistic.
-I love it actually.
I think it's fantastic.
I do want to hear
about "The Squeeze" too.
And tell everyone the reason
behind the name, "The Squeeze."
And what is the idea
behind the podcast?
-The short version is we both
are passionate
about mental health,
and the podcast is
a mental-health-based podcast.
My wife was a nurse
through COVID.
-Wow.
-And kind of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, she's incredible.
But after going through that,
she --
she realized
that she had to take a step back
to kind of prioritize
her mental health.
She deals with a lot
of that stuff still today.
And we kind of just started both
of our mental-health journeys
around the same time.
Me realizing I had to just,
like,
address things
that I just pushed down
and never really thought about,
just the way that I grew up
being in the spotlight
since a kid.
And I just never -- I never
thought about it that way.
And I was like, you know what?
I need to, like,
take this seriously.
And we started that together.
So it was really awesome
to have each other
going through that journey.
This was, you know,
right around COVID time,
you know, kind of like
the journey for many of us.
-Yeah.
-And from that we were like,
we feel called
to do this podcast
and just have vulnerable
conversations with ourselves,
our guests, so...
-And then "The Squeeze" is...?
-"The Squeeze"
is just the juice
of your mental health.
-Yeah. The squeeze.
-Yes. We get into it.
We don't hold back.
-Yeah. Life gives you lemons.
-Yeah.
-Make lemonade.
-Yes. Absolutely.
That's what we're trying to do.
-Yeah.
-It's not easy.
-No. That's fantastic that
you're doing this.
I mean,
I'm sure you've learned a lot.
I mean, since you started this,
I mean, you talk to experts
and you talk to all these --
It's just --
And people that are
experiencing this stuff.
It's great that you're putting
it out there and doing this.
I want to talk to you
about an unexpected call
that you got not too long ago
about you starring
in a Taylor Swift music video.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was awesome. It was so fun.
Talk about this.
Where were you?
Where did it happen?
-Oh, my goodness,
I was at home.
It was like a morning
around 9 a.m.
I get a call from my manager
and he goes,
"You will never believe who I
got a call from this morning."
And I go, "I wouldn't,
so why don't you tell me?"
And he goes,
"Taylor Swift's manager.
And she wants to see
if she can get
your new updated cellphone
number and reach out."
I was like..."O-kay.
Did they say what about?"
He's like, "Not really."
I'm like, "Okay."
He goes, "Do you want to talk
to your wife about this?
Make sure it's okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, wife is like
right in the kitchen there
and she's freaking out.
And I go, "No,
by the signs of it,
I think she's going to be
just fine."
She's the biggest Swifty ever.
So, automatic permission.
And then yeah,
Taylor reached out,
pitched me the idea.
The idea was incredible.
-And you guys
had known each other?
-Yeah. Yeah, but we had been
out of touch for a while,
so it was a real cool,
full-circle moment
for both of us, and then we
jetted off to Liverpool,
England, shot the video.
-Why Liverpool?
-We were going
to do it in London.
But then, you know, she's
experienced at these things.
She realized there
would probably be too many
like paparazzi and media
because we wanted
to keep it a secret.
-Yeah, of course.
-For the big reveal.
-It was a great surprise.
-It was. It turned out perfect.
-It was unbelievable.
I loved it,
but then she premiered it,
I want to say, in Kansas City.
-Yes.
Yeah.
So after we finished filming,
a couple of months go by
and she's like, "No pressure.
I got this crazy idea.
I was thinking, you know,
the night that my album drops,
just blind premiering it
at my show in Kansas City,
and people are going to freak.
They're going to faint. Like,
it's going to be unbelievable.
And then after we show
the video, you and the cast
are going to walk out
and you'll actually be there."
I was like, "Sign me up."
So we did.
-But wait, but let me
just tell you something.
Not only did you come out
and make an entrance,
you made quite the entrance.
-This is so ridiculous.
-No, this is my favorite.
You know it.
We all saw it and we love it.
But I want to show if anyone
didn't see Taylor Lautner,
here's him making an entrance
at the concert.
Look at this.
-Tay-Tay, do you want to
come out?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, no. Aaaaaaah!
[ Applause ]
-Did you -- First of all --
First of all, that's amazing.
Were you nervous at all
for a second and go like,
"What am I doing?
I'm not going to do
a flip" or what --
What went through your mind?
-I know. I do this weird thing
and it doesn't make sense,
so forgive me.
But when I freak out
and I'm really nervous
and I black out,
I just go straight to backflip.
[ Laughter ]
So I stepped out of this door
and I saw this, like, this,
whatever, this walkway.
And it was like 60 yards
down the field.
And I'm like, "I have to walk
down this whole thing?
This is going to be
so uncomfortable."
I was like, "Just backflip,
and I'll take up the space
and it'll be over."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was awesome.
That could have gone so wrong.
-Oh, it could have.
-It could have gone so wrong.
And it went so right.
Well done, buddy.
-Thank you.
-In the video, by the way,
you do some epic fight scenes
and I read somewhere
that Taylor Swift
knew you pretty well,
so she was like,
"No, I know that Taylor Lautner
can do these stunts."
You did your own stunts
for a lot of these movies.
She's like, "No,
he knows how to do this."
-Yeah.
-Do you know how to do that?
And did I know that you knew
how to do that?
-I don't know, but yeah,
she knew
of my martial arts background.
She's just incredible.
So I trusted her
with everything. But yeah.
-Could you show me a move?
-Could I show you a move?
-I mean, I don't know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is there a move
that I could learn?
-Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah, I got an idea.
So there was a move
I did in the video,
but there's
a simpler version of it
and that's called
a tornado kick.
And I think -- I think you're
going to be able to do this.
-Alright.
-What do I do? That sounds --
-Okay.
So I'll take you step by step.
-Yeah.
-So I'm going to show you
like a slow version first.
So here.
-Am I going to be okay here?
-You're going to go --
Yeah. Come on up.
You can walk through
this first part with me.
-I don't want to step
into the tornado.
-I'm not going to do it
full out right now.
-Alright.
-We're going to take it
slow first.
-Yes.
-So just face this way.
-Okay.
-With your left foot,
you're going to go step
and then right foot's
going to come around here.
Left foot knee
is going to go up.
And then the right foot
is going to kick.
So when you put it together
I'll show you
what that looks like.
So it's step,
turn, left, kick.
So it's tornado kick, step,
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think you got it.
-I know step, turn.
-Step, turn, left leg comes up,
and the right one kicks.
-Step, turn.
-Left up and kick.
Yes, that's going to be it.
You got it.
[ Laughter ]
Turn left.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do we have to see it
in slow mo?
Do I have to watch it
Let's just watch.
This is sad. Look at grandpa.
Ahhhhhhhhh, aaah, oh!
[ Laughter ]
Fell down.
-You got that leg up there.
-Taylor Lautner, everybody.
His podcast,
"The Squeeze," is streaming now.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on.